the President of the European Council
Donald Tusk says EU leaders have agreed
to the UK's request to an extension to
the time it has to leave the European
Union Britain was due to leave in three
days time October the 31st but UK MPs
did force the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson to request another delay to give
them more time to scrutinize his new
deal now the new deadline is to be three
months that's an extension January the
31st later today mr. Johnson is expected
to ask MPs to vote on holding a snap
election on December the 12th in return
for more time to argue over the UK's
divorce from the EU Lawrence Lee joins
us live from London Lawrence what's
happened to do or die in a ditch then
well in fairness and we'll come to this
he could actually use it to his
advantage Boris Johnson but yes on one
level it's it's a humiliation Downing
streets briefing journalists right now
so we'll find out soon enough what Boris
Johnson thinks but as you say according
to the law now that the EU has granted
this they'll write it down and send it
to Boris Johnson within 24 hours
according to the law he has immediately
to accept the extension it's a flexible
extension could gone see in the January
if he gets his voter breaks it through
Parliament's in the meantime then the UK
could leave earlier the thing that seems
to have swung it for the European Union
because they had said they wouldn't
grant the extension unless they knew
that something was going to happen to
alter the balance like an election for
example which looks like the most likely
thing the thing that since was swung it
is the promise or the suggestion by two
of the opposition parties a Scottish
nationalists and the Liberal Democrats
to help Boris Johnson change the law so
that Sogetsu votes in favour of an
election he doesn't have to get a
two-thirds majority in parliament but
only a simple majority instead and that
seems now to be the way it'll go we
don't know that Downing Street going to
accept that idea from Liberal Democrats
and the SNP but it seems very likely now
that there will be an election because
the extension has to happen according to
the law that's been passed in the
parliaments here we're almost in
November so that means what they've got
five and a half or six weeks to call an
election stage it and then I guess in
reality that election would
be a general election will it actually
be another referendum on brexit or a
referendum type vote on mr. Johnson
versus mr. Corbyn visa via their
policies to do with yeah yeah that's
that that's exactly the point certainly
Downing Street will want to present
Boris Johnson as the man who is trying
to act on behalf of the people against a
parliament which is dithering and
dragging its heels and doesn't want
brexit that sort of people versus
Parliament thing obviously is already
their strategy and in one sense it
doesn't matter for Boris Johnson if he
does or doesn't get his bill through if
he does get his brexit through he'll go
to the people saying I'm the man who got
brexit done if he doesn't he'll say I'm
the man who wants to do brexit for you
and it's the Parliament gets in the way
so still vote for me
and so in that sense Downing Street will
see it as a win-win for him but the
question as you as you very rightly say
is going to be a gauge of the public
mood
do they like his version of brexit and
more profoundly still two people
actually and now at this point one
brexit to happen at all and if is as
perfectly still perfectly possible
there's yet another hung Parliament's as
we have at the moment no majority will
run off screaming into the night don't
we because it never ends we'll all they
down in a darkened room I think okay
Lawrence good to talk to you thanks very
much